what's happening reject nation we are
gonna watch marvel's what if season one
episode three today i wanna thank
everyone who has been watching this show
with us it's been an awesome journey so
far please go ahead subscribe and click
that notification mother get notified
when our next reaction is up while
you're at it if you end up enjoying our
reaction please go ahead and hit that
like button as always full length watch
along as we stick with the time coder
over at our patreon page cover a whole
plethora of shows over there last but
not least pratham jindal thanks for
editing now these highlights for us bud
you make our job easier let's swing into
action people
[Music]
there was an idea
to bring together
to see if they could become something
more i know i've heard the speech then
you realize what's at stake which is why
i'm surprised you'd want to bet the
future of the avengers initiative on
that
okay
you become a problem a problem i have to
deal with contrary to your belief you
are not the center of my universe i get
it
that's lithium dioxide it's going to
take the edge off it's not a cure
it just
abates the symptoms oh
what oh
[Music]
i see the crucible that would transform
this collection of individuals into a
team of heroes
at least that's how things played out in
one universe
but in this one oh no
[Laughter]
i may not have been a fan of tony stark
but i didn't kill him save your spin for
pierce oh she's being blamed
this wasn't me i know that you know
these won't hold me oh i'm counting on
it someone inside shield compromised
stark's antidote i need someone on the
outside to find out who hmm
so serious
she's gonna have her water soldier
moment yeah you guys are no fun here
mind holding these
oh
kicks
ah
come on
best we can tell
it's extremely powerful and not from
around here
oh got a perimeter breach multiple
agents down
whoa
i got visual on the intruder
oh
cajun male mid-20s with
just say the word
hold your fire i want to see this
is he going to lift it this time
whoa golson wasn't lying about the hair
it's nice
yuri now we're never
it looked like a shot
i have a feeling it might be loki
martin sticking to a story he's pretty
bent out of shape in there won't talk to
anyone he'll talk to me
nah look we'd be too obvious i don't
know
it could be
maybe this is how he wins new york
barton
coulson get a medic who did you let in
here no come on stay with me
wow
even while rotting he smells like
lavender
still there's not a lot connecting a
billionaire playboy and a shield
assassin unless you have any ideas
there
was an idea
that that captain marvel seen at the
morgue
dr ross not sure if you remember me but
hey
i'm here about tony stark i believe he
was murdered using this you're an expert
in the tactical applications of cellular
biology
why did you really come here
i need to keep this off shield's radar
and you seem to have some experience in
that department
also to get betty ross back
whatever it was it wasn't biological
your antidote didn't even make it out of
the syringe
oh
you're thinking
nanotech i'm a biologist not a
ballistics expert
and i believe we're done here
no
a student must have left it there yeah
student seems our killer is going after
the candidates if someone wanted to
kneecap shield that's a good place to
start
who else is on the list brucy
bruce banner you need to get yourself
the ground first find bannon i think i
already have
i i'm sorry bud i can't let you in there
move or i'll make you move no need for
violence
[Laughter]
not gonna work out
for anyone they recast edward jordan
what you've been here
who is the killer
by frost
oh boy
whatever it is oh no oh he brought the
rv
midgard there's our boy okay so it's not
[Applause]
loki i sort of can't die
then i guess you're in luck
look alive people i want strike teams
locked loaded and ready to move in that
is not his voice
i have bruce banner in my custody you
need to stand down
who the hell opened fire not us sir
we're clear
it's okay we're okay right i'll get you
out of this hulk out
come on
agent romano i think you might be better
off getting out of here
what's in the box
such insolence will not be tolerated and
your planet will be taken as retribution
take it down
whoa
oh damn wow
bad ass this time
the general isn't the one who started
this then who did
oh he was shot with something else
don't explode don't explode don't
explode
wow
but he can't die
he he can't die
explosion there
declaring war on this planet will not
bring your prince back
wait
he's not wrong
the person who killed your brother also
killed two of my people good people you
have until the next rise of midgard sun
to deliver my brother's assassin
first stop the public library
gotta do some research
was your friend too hashtag
steve steve steve
wow
good one coltson what no nothing that's
great thank you how casual her delivery
really is a fan of that guy
jenna van dyke yeah how did a woman who
died two years ago accessed the database
yesterday
oh is it like ant-man or
something like that maybe
not against me
not against shield
is it hank pym
you found me
oh damn they just killed her off too
all the avengers should die
it's hard it's all about heart
oh
sir i understand that this prince loki
situation is the very reason you
proposed the avengers initiative for a
group of remarkable individuals to fight
the battles we can't i wrote the speech
there's still one name left sir
yours
[Music]
i'm not the only avenger left
capitan
is that a beeper it's all about
hope
either make a pact with a god or deal
with the devil
the dark episode man
that does
you got a name soldier
i'm here to see you all
[Music]
maybe it is hank van it isn't hank yeah
you have to come here
and stand over her grave oh don't worry
about her i doubt she'd mind considering
she's dead she died
because shield killed her oh he's
yellowjacket
she was my daughter you took everything
from me
i wanted you to hurt damn
everything you ever worked for
oh
shoot oh no
oh oh jeez
oh
damn this guy brutal
yo
whoa
that's right he injected himself here
[Music]
wow
a fury
fury you're still uh
pretty surprised for a guy with a corner
office
you're supposed to be a killer well come
on in
kill me
oh no
don't desecrate
[Music]
nice so he is working okay that's right
working with loki oh
yeah
yeah
dang
[Laughter]
clever even i was fooled
[Laughter]
what's with the goth kid hello
trickster god hi shield is people
people willing to give their lives for
something greater than themselves hmm
now take your hammer and get off my
planet
about that we should be allies you know
i just had an idea i was thinking i
might extend my stay here on midgar oh
god i don't know
oh god oh no
oh no no
[Laughter]
that's what i'm talking about
it is with great pride that i stand
before you today to announce that in
just one day's time
the nations of earth have put aside
their differences and united
under my command
wow
so i have come
to help you fulfill
your destiny
way to go loki
finally come out on top the avengers
were always meant to be more than a team
they were an idea to believe that in our
darkest hour we will find our heroes
hope never dies as long as someone keeps
their good eye on the bigger picture
welcome back captain
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're late
it was like a black mirror episode yeah
yeah
like an almost slashery flavor
yeah it's freaking pamela of orgies
the other shield agents weren't paying
attention
they were busy
he couldn't swim
supposed credit scene
nope nope there's no point in
appreciating the heart efforts of all
those acknowledged who worked on this
episode nope don't care don't care never
will
who needs people working on stuff like
these anyway just give me the next
episode that's right
all right guys
i actually did hear about this episode
because originally they did have uh
scarlett johansson in the voice for it
but after the whole like lawsuit debacle
they had to replace her at the last
minute because they didn't want i'm just
totally messing with you guys
really they moved that fast
and they got somebody with as much clout
as like a lake bell's got you know a
pretty good profile in hollywood
come on when she pops up how does your
mind kind of not go there absolutely i
mean absolutely
yeah that's uh i was just messing with
you guys that's not true at all this is
a great match because the first parts of
the episode i was like huh i wonder how
this works into all the different
conflict that's recently arisen but it
doesn't
uh oh you mean did you think it was
scarlett johansson um i thought it was a
good match oh
didn't sound like her enough oh
well not enough uh you should get the
extras got that like rasp in her voice
yeah she's got a little
baritone kind of
you know she's got a really armed
scarlet joy
he's a base actually yes in real life
she just has to pitch it way up for
interviews i love colin jost
i'm black widow disney where's my money
nah man uh yeah this was an interesting
hybrid after coming off of the first
episode which felt very much like
a remake of first avenger and then this
one and then the the second episode um
really doing its own thing after a very
pivotal point from picking up instead of
peter quill they pick up t'challa and
then
here was like a hodgepodge of a whole
bunch of like alternate takes
revisiting very familiar moments
and then watching the outcome of
all that happen i really enjoyed it i do
think that
def like this has been kind of a common
thing i've been my mind has been going
to for each one of these episodes not so
much with episode two i only thought
episode tv like five more minutes uh
yeah i do think this could have used
like an extra 10 minutes to really uh
wring out a little bit more
tension and uh breathing room to feel a
little bit more of the suspense of it
all
but for the most part for like a
bite-sized dark version of like the
death of the avengers before they even
have a chance to assemble i thought they
did a really good job it made for an
interesting watch
ha ha ha
an interesting watch but it also lent
itself to um what i thought to be a
rather
clever twist on
the whole foray here because
yeah i mean like when you meet when you
meet hank pym in the first ant-man movie
he he is very much
disturbed by the the vanishing of
his uh of his wife
right um but that's okay there's
janet is the one janet is the wife hope
is the daughter so hope die so like
yes janet's wife hope daughter so is
janet still alive here is that what they
said on that computer screen i couldn't
yeah i thought it didn't seem like she
had a red x for dead or did i did i miss
a line of dialogue yeah yeah no i mean i
took it as as yes maybe she's still out
there somewhere in the corner
maybe that piece of information holds up
and yeah she's not like confirmed dead
well i mean like when you meet hank pym
in um ant-man you know one of the things
that i that you think at least what i
pick up on michael douglas's portrayal
is what keeps him
not becoming a villain is the fact that
he has a daughter he cares about you
know like there's more to it than that
but yeah it's like you can totally see
that scenario that if this guy lost hope
the the one the one thing that would
like
was good in his life a guy who had been
robbed of so much
and his brilliant inventor
and someone who fought for this country
fought for the world and and so if he
loses hope yeah the dude would crack the
dude would
go down this path and i liked how there
was like an actual personal thing and
imbued in
the choice of villainy for this
character it's not just what if he was
bad you know uh that there was a real
purpose
uh behind his motives
for all of this so i i actually
quite appreciated that touch and i and i
like the commitment to the animation of
really making him
appear like twisted and crazy and dark
circles under his eyes and never
sleeping and you feel like he doesn't
eat and yeah yeah he's like his whole
life has been consumed by this at this
point yeah he's just crazed i i enjoyed
that i enjoyed that little touch and it
was there's some deaths in here that
definitely surprised me hulk hulk
exploding oh dude it was like oh damn
they're gonna do that aren't they
they're gonna do it are they yeah they
brought back betty ross
who is not played right not uh here we
got the names here stephanie panicello
definitely not live tyler
it is what i thought i mean i think it
would have been a little cool if they
made it edward i think it would have
been really cool
you're just not gonna mess up with the
continuity i mean mark ruffalo is uh
he's lovable he's lovable mark ruffalo
and he is who we know as the hulk now
um and he's been the hulk many many
times now in the mcu
i just think it would have been uh a
little bit more fun a little bit more
time more cheeky yeah it would have been
more fun if if it was edward norton of
like damn they did that
i never thought they would have gotten
at least like make him in the likeness
of edward norton yeah yeah something to
make a self-aware nod to that because it
still remain and with as much as like in
these later phases they have gone back
to re-legitimize less beloved marvel
films i i am kind of i get why because
of the rights with universal but it is
kind of a bummer that they can't do more
of at least nodding to that film because
it's you know one of the phase one
movies
i mean this is the one that did the most
nodding to it yeah i've had any of them
but it would have been cool still to see
where norton yeah like they're
practically i like how they do recreate
the scenes but then have like completely
different outcomes because they all just
keep dying yeah yeah yeah
and there's some things in the remake
touch that they do enhance more like
coulson gets to be more of a character
here even hawkeye got to be more of a
character than he was as a little tiny
cameo in the first thor movie you got to
have like
more dialogue well he feels more like an
actual member of an actual team in this
whereas you know in the thor movie he's
just kind of like oh you're one of
fury's guys right
yeah like everybody else with colson all
the agents like they're kind of what
feels like the team in that movie
whereas here it's like he's already got
avengers
like he's yeah you know hope uh you know
at least he had hope i mean this is all
building the avengers to having their
showdown with loki
and you know you eliminate the avengers
one by one and then you get this
scenario here where you're like oh
that's kind of neat oh loki's teaming up
with him to take down their okay but now
this opens the door for loki to to
conquer hence the necessity of the
avengers i kind of wish it just ended on
the bleak note
i know i would have been happy with that
like oh it's just bad for them but you
know they give you that
that hopeful touch at the end with the
two caps captain america and then
captain marvel showing up at the end
there yeah you know which is that's what
nick fury would do so it's not like it's
not in tune with the character to to go
out and try that yeah uh i just thought
it would have been like a real black
mirror commitment it would have just
ends
the world is lost and this is why we
needed the avengers yeah absolutely yeah
and i mean yeah that like i find it
interesting because it almost seems as
though part of the motif is that oh you
get all these changes and stuff like
that and they all kind of equal
something sinister by the end and so
yeah i guess this one sort of went with
okay we have a very sinister ending so
now we have to allude to you know the
the reverse of that because like the
last one with t'challa it's like you
know you kind of cut away to a related
but not ultimately to the plot of the
episode situation which turns into
you're like oh this is gonna turn out
worse than you expected whereas here i
mean yeah it seems like this story could
easily continue and i i don't know i've
heard you know tell that certain
characters will you know recur over this
season and so i'd be curious to see if
they come back to this ever at any point
uh because yeah like they do just leave
the door wide open for loki to take over
and like i enjoyed the weird like
shining motif of doing like monday
tuesday and having it almost be
sort of like a slasher scenario where
yeah someone's picking off all the
avengers before we can even get the team
and then when loki shows up you know
there's a bit of a subversion where it's
like oh he's not just here to conquer
he's actually here to avenge and you
know
seek retribution for thor's death which
is you know just like an interesting
flavorful twist on his character not to
say that he's like totally cool with
thor in this universe but still you know
it
hints at slightly different character
ties and you get the sense that every
time we check into one of these parallel
stories you know the characters do have
slightly different sensibilities and
that helps it to feel more alive and
whatnot
um oh it's kind of it is weird because
you don't know what happened like
you think odin would step in or
something like that if you're trying to
recall the first thor movie but you know
loki
was happy with thor being banished yeah
absolutely you know so for him to show
up with all the force of asgard you know
unless it's solely manipulation i mean
it must have been a manipulative tactic
you know like oh now that he's dead we
can i can unite and prove myself as
leader
in this scenario but i don't feel like
odin would allow for
um
oh wait is thor one when odin goes to
sleep or is that thor the dark world
charming
that's dark world right
i mean i'm not gonna lie guys i've only
seen the dark world one time oh all this
time dude it's the one to catch up on
now it's down at the mcu it's the only
one i've seen once yeah yeah yeah every
other one i've seen at least a couple of
times but um
yeah yeah i think it's the
yes okay because yeah odin banishes him
in the first horror movie
but
yeah i mean i don't know i don't know
because thor gained odin's approval by
the end of the first movie isn't that
part of his art oh yeah he has to learn
how to be worthy of the hammer yeah
and we don't even have any of that to
deal with this yeah so i was
yeah because i remember in thor after he
fails to pick up the hammer loki visits
him when he's um when he is uh
held in their little shield
new mexico entertainment
yeah
um
i mean this was a this was a fun one uh
i do think that i do prefer the second
one still overall my favorite yeah
second one's still my favorite i love
more of the concepts of what they're
doing and it is exciting to see like oh
you got nick fury here who you know sam
jackson really gets a chance to shine in
it and it's it is cool
that
your
your story about avengers being offed
nick fury is the lead yeah of it you
know because he he really this really is
his episode as protagonist
so that was cool and like black widow's
like main supporting character along
with coulson so it was neat to like the
the the avengers were usually front and
center as avengers and then these guys
were usually like people in the back
yeah i get to be the front and center
for the episode so i really like that
touch and i did like how it
progressively got darker
uh but i wasn't i wasn't ever really
quite emotionally
caught up in it the way how i would like
to have been like i again it was another
situation where i found myself like
having fun feeling that in a genuine way
admiring it
and really appreciating what they're
doing and the concepts but
still in the in the in the fields i'm
not like really caught up in the
suspense so much but more in like it's
kind of like my heart's a little not as
as a tad detached but my mind is really
like interested in what's going on i
don't know how to explain this is a
whole process of like thought logic
versus emotion that i'm trying to
explain to you guys yeah yeah yeah i i
think i can kind of pick up what you're
what you're getting at there because
there is a certain element of like it's
it's all like these three episodes have
each been really fun to see what the
next development's going to be what the
next you know twist on the familiar is
going to be what the next curve ball is
going to be but yeah like here watching
this episode
it didn't really feel like a big oh damn
moment when you realize or it's revealed
who's behind all this and why it feels
just kind of like a development of the
plot and so like i feel like well they
just move so fast and that's the thing
is like there is an element of punch and
suspense that leads to the punch that i
think maybe gets sort of diluted by
having yeah them feel so fast paced and
and having to cram so much into a
smaller window of time they feel
more
like a comic strip or something that's
not quite as yeah like emotionally
substantial not that these have to be
like i'm curious to know what their
desired uh uh effect on the audience is
for this like
argumentative wise yeah that might that
might just be what they want they want
to achieve is
just these like bite-sized like comics
you know working right side stories yeah
yeah um
i don't know i just i just thought that
like the episode two reached another
height
so i i kind of would expect it to still
reach that and
you know like that i really feel like
we're also kind of giving it a pass
because of that fact but
same time you know like i've seen some
pretty damn great gripping
animated shows that are usually more
serial it's not like this where
everything's very i know like some of
these are bound to tie in or whatever or
become more connected to the live action
in some way uh and i'm hearing captain
carter supposed to return at some point
and that chadwick bow's been filmed
four episodes four episodes but it might
not be the same t'challa yeah you know
what i mean like this nick fury and
hawkeye
is not the same as the one that we saw
at the end of captain carter episode
because otherwise they would have called
him captain court
unless she just died and then
no there would have been there wouldn't
be steve rogers in the ice yeah if that
was the case because that is it wouldn't
be the same universe yeah so this is a
different version of them but they still
got you know sam jackson and jeremy
renner to uh appear in the first episode
i think that was them but they still got
them to appear in there
so
while we're hearing that oh no this
actor signed on for this many episodes
they might not be the same
um
yeah you know i do think that that that
is a bit of a
every episode has so far been like
interesting and fascinating and there's
concepts about it that i'm
impressed by and choices i really admire
a lot
i even liked when freaking nick fury was
taunting uh hank pym at the end of
fighting with him because and there's
one line he because he picks up this
vial
and i thought i was like oh did he
inject himself whatever the vial is
and that's why he's got the strength and
it took me a while to be like oh no it's
loki um
i mean obviously picked up on it before
the
clear revelation
but there is a line that he has in there
where he or nick fury says like i don't
care about any of them and i was like
what what yeah what does that mean yeah
like a weird thing that's a weird
character choice and then that was a
hint that that is not nick fury that's
loki
uh so yeah like little things like that
and there's like easter eggs sprinkled
in throughout and and it often has you
like thinking of the live-action movie
so this
i prefer something more like episode two
instead of some
this had a kind of uh the hybrid touch
of
like episode one is if you're a big fan
of that live action movie you're gonna
love this and this is like if if you're
a fan of the live actions you'll
appreciate this and and i'm kind of i
don't i'm not even sure what it is i'm
really wanting from this
not even sure what it is i i want
because this essentially did what i like
what i want what if to do and i like the
episode quite a bit i just i guess i
just that's just what it comes down to i
just want to feel a little bit more
um you know more the emotional [ __ ] like
feel the loss of these people instead of
just go interesting yeah yeah because
from what we know about them that should
register as a pretty grave course change
yeah and from here like again because
the episode's moving so quick
yeah yeah it's like you you don't have
time i guess to fully process or latch
on to the loss of all of the avengers
yeah and yeah it's like i feel like if
i'm looking at this just through the
scope of yeah it's an animated series
it's a cartoon you know it has like all
the desired flavors and beets and stuff
that a cartoon ought to have and i think
what i'm starting to wonder is like this
to me is sort of caught in the middle
because you have so much stuff that
we've seen for decades now that's been
you know big live action and it has a
certain level of resonance that comes
with it and now here like i love the
transcription of everything to this
medium
but at the same time yeah it's
i've been conditioned to expect a
certain level of yeah like emotional
weight or a heavy toll when losses take
place and this series exists in a weird
space where yeah like these are all
hypotheticals or they're alternate
universes and so i feel like that can
undercut stakes to begin with to some
extent and so each of these episodes
individually needs to raise those stakes
and get you sort of in that like oh god
like how's nick fury going to get out of
this who's who's doing this um and i
feel like that's what
that would be the gripe i have
most that's usually sort of uh touched
upon by us going this needs to be a
little longer yeah you know it's like
yeah i i might things feel more like
developments than revelations or twists
or or big like oh no you know i mean it
didn't have me going on the to give it
credit
i was like i have no idea who this
killer is i have no idea who's doing it
i can't figure it out and then i thought
the reveal was smart but that's what i
mean it's like i think they got a really
good handle on plot and plot beats it's
just more of the the nuance underneath
which i know a lot of people disagree
with us on and uh that's completely fine
you're like if you feel for it then [ __ ]
i wish i had your feelings
yeah i mean it's still fun and episodic
and yeah it's like if this isn't an
intended to make you be like oh no you
know when the you know whatever
crescendo apparel happens and it is
supposed to be a little bit lighter then
i think they're nailing that yeah yeah
you know it's just i think if you're
especially if you're getting like the
actual actors to appear in here yeah i
mean sometimes it's a little distracting
when it's obviously not them yeah yeah
so it's a certain voice waiting for an
episode where that doesn't happen yeah
because you start kidding like what i
mean i don't know how that is for some
people it might not bother them but for
it starts becoming a game of is that
them is that not them you know yeah
because when you have so many returners
so it's not like the special thing stops
being that you got people to return the
special thing starts being who didn't
yeah
but yeah that's just opinion overall i
mean i'd still give this episode like a
seven out of ten yeah yeah i still enjoy
myself i still enjoyed it quite a bit it
was a solid episode and it still makes
me want to continue you know yeah
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that bell hit
that like button what did you think
about the episode hey we'll catch you
guys soon
[Music]